[Music]
aroof today I'm talking to hood of Zetas
about trust in politics he worked
extremely closely with the late former
Chancellor Helmut Kohl
mr. site has welcome to the DW interview
done Thanks
Sundari to have you with us my name is
Thomas van misters itis when communist
East Germany collapsed the wall fell and
German reunification was being forged
you were head of the chancellor's office
and one of Helmut Kohl's closest
confidants did his death mark the
passing of your former boss or of a
friend Bob Dole and point one should be
a bit cautious about using the term a
friend especially when the other person
was such a remarkable figure in world
history but I was certainly a confidant
of Helmut cord and we understood each
other almost instinctively in pushpa yet
no he stayed in touch even after his
retirement from politics knocked him I
kept in touch with him after he withdrew
from politics I also visited him last
year and during those difficult months I
spoke to his wife on the phone and heard
from her how he was doing and so on
the point is though your friendship
endured until the end of his life that
isn't something many can say as we will
come to later but first let us talk
about the dramatic days of unification
after the Berlin Wall fell and you were
with him almost day and night then how
close was your working relationships
fires in a yard or he would call come to
me well Helmut Kohl knew me from my many
years of work in the parliamentary party
I was head of the parliamentary group
and like Wolfgang schäuble er before me
we knew every facet of the group's work
indle about the links to our coalition
partners and about the guidelines we had
to follow when making decisions
I don't lean Ian liebe through I can
happen via Barney we also saw potential
threats and had to make sure that any
legislation was passed without major
complications so he already had been in
close
on tap for years desking up that often
went well into the night I believe so
much was changing so rapidly then and
required a constant response did you
overnight sometimes in the Chancellery
of infinite qualities like that used to
start at 7:00 a.m. the Chancellor was
always at his desk by hull parser if he
hadn't already called you at 6 o'clock
if he hadn't already phoned before it
went in the door and they finished if
the Chancellor had no evening
appointments in his bungalow finally
yeah they're my point of view these were
very very important out because after
the hustle and bustle of the day we
could sometimes discuss basic issues in
peace and quiet
really so we the members of helmet cause
star we've got to know his films as
goals and what he wanted and we could
talk about one via quantum so yes
especially in the days when we were
concerned with getting the refugees out
of the German embassies in Prague Warsaw
and Budapest in other words getting
clearance for them to leave for West
Germany in wouldn't've the autumn we did
spend some nights I think indeed dodging
butcher Parkway show and would have
lifted chemical chemical armed personal
direct connections and he loved the
telephone he also called you when he
offered you the job at the Chancellery
how did that work cancel and what
happened just the gig just wasn't
comfortable huh uliana vivo it was all
quite normal
uliana Weber put him through and he
asked me what I was doing I told him I
was mowing the lawn that's a worthwhile
activity he replied but there are also
worthwhile activities in bondic
underneath the forum then he asked if I
had a black suit was pretty relaxed and
yes I knew what it was about and what
all you needed at first for the job as a
black suit but mr. situs Sat phone calls
this kind of direct communication were
also characteristic of his way of
working that's how he governed isn't it
oh yeah if you live really well many
people talk about the call system some
of them disparagingly
I've never said anything derogatory
about it was simply a system he himself
described he surrounded himself with an
explosive circle of advisers month-old
fiddles with people who were loyal to
him who he could discuss anything
without him becoming public knowledge
that's how he gained access to expert
information over and above what the
ministries had given him in writing and
when he needed to find out more he
reached for the phone he had people he
could ask everywhere did loyalty mean no
dissent was tolerated doc in being on
the contrary my some people think that
helmet call was like that and wouldn't
Brook any contradiction no no if we did
have some intense discussions
I also remember some controversial
discussions such as with horse tell chip
the foreign policy advisor who is one of
helmet cause most important people or
the economic policy adviser Ludovic
there was dissent from me from Scheidler
you know we all did it in our own ways
but he insisted any dissent must be
justified if someone turned up and
talked about something superficially
then he could react quite sharply and
harshly well done all did he get history
roll towards you and swept you up you
were one of the very few in addition to
the then US president bush senior to be
told in advance about Helmut Kohl's
10-point plan for unification the world
was taken by surprise including Foreign
Minister Genki did you have any
misgivings about that it's alma he
clobbered us said that he would call the
future I think Helmut Kohl feared his
idea and his ten-point plan could be
talked to death or meet opposition
therefore it never got off the ground
definitely kundan that would have been
very unpleasant because we wanted to
send out a signal a chancellor wanted to
send out this signal and as far as the
Free Democrats were concerned we were
convinced that it would be leaked
straight away and then it wouldn't be a
surprise the next morning
bleiben vo let's stay with your own
opinion also your differences with
Helmut Kohl you later became Germany's
interior minister and resigned after a
Red Army Faction terrorist was killed in
a police operation under what were at
the time unexplained circumstances Pat
punished Carl was totally against you
resigning but you decided to go against
him how hard was that maybe it was a bit
disloyal to do something the Chancellor
actually didn't want enjoyed a new
function and worked with his after then
I had a decisive point why I resigned in
a sentence was that I no longer had the
reins in my hand but a minister doesn't
resign until he has told the head of
government the life also I was glad when
I finally reached him after two and a
half hours
he was totally opposed we talked three
times on the phone and probably also
confirmed with other people but I told
him our Chancellor I've never asked you
for anything but now I ask you to
respect my decision to give him holiday
that's when he gave in but on the
condition that I would say he had not
wanted me to take this step he had
neither entitled before me Anika
whatever to think my hammies monument
Helmut Kohl later got a few cracks after
he as head of the CDU concealed two
million Deutschmarks in illegal
donations in secret accounts did your
picture of Helmut Kohl also developed
cracks the cabbar that I suffered
particularly from the fact that the
relationship between Helmut Kohl and
vault gang troy blur was shattered or at
least split apart and of course the
debates in the party at that time also
showed how shaken up it was by all this
as was the public or in Depok I could
say to be off duty but I'd but the
bottom line of even subsequently I have
to say one tell much Schmidt said in my
mind quite rightly everything we discuss
we should also discuss critically but as
far as the illegal donations affair is
concerned it won't tarnish or a clip
helmut dolls historic performance as a
German and a European NIC machine and I
share that opinion does his likely minor
my name dr. D um I'm just wanders you
mentioned that some of helmet calls
friendships were shattered back then and
he also quarreled with his sons soon
incest but good one therefore say he
isolated himself at the end dad was
awesome nd ziba is anger Matt as far as
his family situation is concerned I
cannot assess the relationships in any
detail anything I say now would be
speculation so let's leave it at that
D Bladon so you remain loyal to your
friend helmet goal at the moment we get
the impression that europe the united
Europe II stood for is dissolving was
Helmut Kohl the last European it is
Tamil cooler let's sort biographies my
anything you know I think that it's also
Chancellor Merkel's goal to strengthen
Europe and act in solidarity in internal
affairs but unfortunately the times have
changed a day we look at Moscow and at
Washington light and we can also see a
lot of national Eggert ISM in Europe
what's go seemed enough Washington would
be there no feeling at another I hope
that what is happening in the world
around us in Turkey in Russia and even
in America will bring the Europeans as a
whole to their senses America just earth
your beer in schizont to live in on
point
we know that nation-states are no longer
able to cope with their own problems we
need a Europe of solidarity let collapse
the death of Helmut Kohl and the fact
that he will be honored with a European
act of state will bring things together
again
finally as we come to the end of our
interview we'd like you to complete
three sentences for us pie hood off site
has find honoring Helmut Kohl with a
European active state yes yes it is
remarkable that something like that has
not happened before but this also shows
the prominent place Helmut call
in the memory of today's generation in
Europe and around the world this is
really Europe bowing down before a great
European or bus for an awards novel beer
today's politicians can learn from
Helmut Kohl VVT how important it is to
have an inner compass to be grounded to
always put yourself in the position of
others even in negotiations according to
the motto
how much can I demand from my opposite
number if the compromise is to last done
as I've said giving and sticking to your
word and we've already touched on the
subject and politics without a personal
relationship of trust with the political
actors this is really problematic it's
difficult problematic
Niq Niq guy and above all not suited to
resolving conflicts if Trust is absent
of indan then came forth on death row
dolls iters thank you for talking to us